today on the matt well show the governor
of utah competes for the title of
biggest coward in the republican party
stiff competition for this but his
threatened veto of a bill meant to keep
men out of women's sports may mean that
he uh wins the prize we'll discuss also
netflix along with visa mastercard and
several other major companies have
suspended operations in russia are these
kinds of measures more likely to help or
hurt in the long run and the white house
is poised to extend the pause on student
loan payments for what reason and where
do they have the authority to do this
not that they're worried about that
we'll talk about that plus the mayor of
new york keeps his priorities in order
by launching a war against chocolate
milk in schools and our daily
cancellation we'll talk about the
trucker convoy which officially arrived
in d.c while around dc anyway this
weekend to i guess protest coveted
restrictions which are most mostly all
lifted anyway so we'll talk about that
and everything else today on the matt
wells show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know using the internet without
expressvpn is like leaving your keys in
your car while you run into the gas
station for a snack most of the time
you're probably fine but what if you
come back to see someone else driving
off with your car every time you connect
to an unencrypted network cafes hotels
airports whatever it is any hacker on
the same network can gain access to your
personal data
and uh that's everything passwords
financial details anything at all
it doesn't take much technical knowledge
to hack somebody just some cheap
hardware as needed uh you know you need
to be about as smart as a 12 year old to
do it which means that i could never do
it but lots of people can expressvpn
protects your personal data from hackers
by creating a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet uh
to take a hacker with a super computer
over a billion years to get past express
express vpn's encryption
so this is a copy we'll have to update
in about a billion years um but for now
you're probably pretty safe and that's
why you need to get expressvpn the best
part about expressvpn is how easy it is
to use all you gotta do is fire up the
app uh click one button to get protected
it also works on all devices such as
phones laptops tablets and everything
else it is really that simple so secure
your online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com walsh that's
e-x-b-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
walsh and you can get an extra three
months free express
expressvpn.com walsh
so it wasn't all bad news from the
republican party last week we have to
admit late in the week on thursday iowa
governor kim reynolds
signed a bill which prohibits males from
participating in female sports in the
state according to the media if you're
dumb enough to trust the headlines iowa
banned trans people from female sports
or from sports in general that's what
that's the way the headlines are being
written but this is uh not what the
legislation accomplished at all in fact
um in fact the neat thing about you know
being literate if you are is that you
can actually go and read the bill for
yourself and if you do that you'll see
that the word transgender actually
doesn't appear in the legislation at all
it's not mentioned anywhere
that by the way is true of every state
that has passed bills protecting women's
sports and i think there are eight or
nine of them now um
none of them mention trans people there
are there are no laws actually banning
trans people from sports nobody anywhere
at any point has even advocated such an
idea instead the bill getting to the
crux of it says this and i'll read from
the bill it says only female students
based on their sex may participate in
any team sport team sport or athletic
event designated as being for females
women or girls
so that's that's it that's basically all
it says uh the bill does not target
trans people any more than laws against
stealing targets kleptomaniacs now just
because one group may feel a special
compulsion to violate a law that doesn't
mean the law itself victimizes or
oppresses them specifically
because as long as the law applies to
everyone equally
now if there's a law that says only
these sorts of people aren't allowed to
do this particular thing but everybody
else is allowed to do it now that is an
unequal law okay that's that's
unconstitutional you can't do that
but in this case all people are required
to play on sports teams consistent with
their biological sex it's a it's a law
that applies to everyone if i
moved to iowa and i wanted to compete in
a women's basketball league i would not
be able to do it even though i'm not
trans you know i would be no more
permitted to play on the girls team than
any man who who identifies as trans
that's what we call equality under the
law where we are all
uh
forbidden from doing the same exact
thing
which is exactly by the way
equality under the law is exactly the
thing that the left fights against all
the time while pretending to fight for
it
now in any case um so there's some
sanity in iowa governor reynolds should
be commended
move to the west a little bit though and
the story is uh very very different the
ap reports quote utah governor spencer
cox said that he plans to veto
legislation past friday
that would ban transgender student
athletes from competing in girls sports
without his support utah is unlikely to
join the 11 states or it's actually 11
states all republican-led that have
recently enacted bans on transgender
girls wanting to compete in school
sports leagues that correspond with
their gender identity vowing to veto the
bill cox directly addressed transgender
student athletes who he said found
themselves on the subject of political
debate through no fault of their own
i just want them to know that it's going
to be okay we're going to work through
this cox said the governor had for
months engaged in behind the scenes
negotiations to broker a compromise
between lgbtq advocates and social
conservatives
after throwing a support behind a
proposal to create a first of its kind
commission of experts in utah to make
decisions on individual transgender
student athletes aiming to participate
cox said he was stunned on friday night
as lawmakers advance and ultimately pass
an amended amended proposal that
included an outright ban on transgender
student athletes competing in girls like
now that's the ap report um
a number of problems with it we we can't
break down all of it i mean pretty much
every sentence there's something wrong
with it and there's propaganda in there
um
uh
including the claim that this is a this
is a
you know
there's a need for a compromise between
quote lgbtq advocates and social
conservatives now it might be true that
social conservatives
tend to be against men competing in
women's sports
that's only because social conservatives
tend to be sane and rational people you
don't need to be a quote social
conservative to have that view you just
need to have some basic common sense
um and also there is no compromise
available there's no compromise between
these two options
either we say that men are men and women
are women and if you're a man you're not
allowed to compete against women or not
i mean those are really the two options
there's no middle ground
yet cox pretended that that's what he
was looking for some sort of middle
ground he was stunned when the band
passed and here he has a here he is at a
press conference expressing his
shock and outrage and emotional pain
listen
we have never discussed a ban um i've
never had a conversation about a ban
with anyone uh this session uh that was
never you know there were hours and
hours days months of of discussion and
trying to find
that right balance and that's really
what we're what we're seeking for and
and i was able to listen to some of the
debate on the senate floor and the truth
is that that everyone has a very valid
point we know the data and and the uh
the suicide rate amongst uh uh our
transgender community is
significantly higher than than anywhere
else that's the one thing i know
the other thing i know is that we don't
have any transgender athletes that are
dominating any sports here in the state
of utah in fact we only have as we
mentioned three or four um and so
uh
so to to to go from
all of this work
and all of this discussion and all of
these negotiations to get to a point
that was uncomfortable for everyone but
but that was a path forward and and
really represents the best of utah to
now on the last night of the session out
of nowhere getting a complete ban that
again nobody's talked to me about um uh
is is is uh
incredibly disappointing
and there we go with the suicide talking
point again here's the here's the
question and they always have to throw
that in there
for the majority of american history
when males
competed against males and females
against females which is how it worked
forever
how many
men
or boys committed suicide because they
weren't able to cross over and compete
against women instead
like how many count them up
through the entirety of american history
up until like right now
has there been an epidemic of suicide
because of this
no of course not
you know in fact if we're bringing
suicide into it it seems at least as
likely to me that a girl might commit
suicide because a boy couldn't um
because a boy came in and stole her
opportunities it's at least as likely as
that would happen as it is that a boy
would commit suicide because he couldn't
compete against the girls
though both seem very unlikely which is
why we shouldn't be having this debate
on these terms anyway
now it's true that trans people have
astronomically higher rates of suicide
in general but as i've clarified many
times those high rates remain high no
matter if they're affirmed or not no
matter if they get surgery or not no
matter what what sports teams they're
competing on because the underlying
problem and source of despair is the
disconnect between the true self and the
perception of the self the solution is
to bring those two things into harmony
with each other by
treating the disordered mind which has
caused the disharmony
the solution is not to encourage the
delusion
let's not let this distract
from the primary point here as it
relates to what just happened in utah
and that is that spencer cox is a timid
trembling faint-hearted slimy little
boneless slug
slithering around
now i don't mean to overstate the case
here and i don't think i could anyway
imagine just how
cowardly you have to be
to cave to the trans lobby in utah of
all places
now salt lake city
and and people live in utah are quick to
remind me of this when i've talked about
this you know salt lake city has its
leftist elements like any city does
sure
but utah broadly speaking is not exactly
the lgbt capital of the world
you know if you're gonna take a stand
like this
you should be able to take it anywhere
in the country but one of the safest
places to take it is in utah
yet the limp [ __ ] curled up into the
fetal position anyway now
granted
he gets 250 000
uh from the pharmaceutical industry you
know during his last campaign he got
quarter million dollars from the
pharmaceutical industry which puts it
among his top donors
um big pharma is all in on the trans
agenda because there are billions of
dollars to be made and which are being
made right now
in fostering gender confusion in
children all of those hormone pills and
puberty blockers add up
um and lots of big pharma executives are
driving nicer cars today because of all
this
so i don't mean to suggest that cox is
just a coward he's also a money-grubbing
con artist as well so let's not
undersell the man i mean his his resume
is more extensive than just being a
cowardice
but leaving his financial motivations
aside
it's worth really reflecting on the
extreme nature of republican cowardice
as displayed by so many of them
especially spencer cox
gender ideology is about as radical and
extreme
as it gets on the left now it's also
mainstream no doubt but it is radical
and extreme in the sense that it's just
about the craziest and least rational
least reasonable thing that the left is
currently pushing not just about it is
so
taking the issue of sport specifically
the leftist position is extraordinarily
unpopular
i mean almost nobody agrees with it in
reality
um
even on the left
they don't
they don't agree with themselves
now they might pretend to
but most of them don't
and i and i know that because most
people generally are saying most people
are not insane you have to be insane to
take the position that there's no real
difference between men and women and so
you can just compete you can you can
combine and it won't make a difference
like you have to be actually an insane
person to believe that and most people
aren't insane despite appearances
a poll was conducted on this issue as it
happens in utah last year and it found
that 61 percent this is what the poll
says i think a ras museum poll and it
found that 61 believe that trans women
quote unquote should not compete on
women's teams
now 61 is already a significant majority
meaning that even if we just take that
61 percent cox caved to the minority
but keep in mind that the actual number
is much higher than 61
because 61 that doesn't account for the
sizeable portion of respondents who are
too afraid to say what they really think
even to a random pollster on the phone
that's the kind of fear this issue
generates in people that they're too
afraid to say it out loud to almost
anyone unless it's just a family member
in their living room and even then they
might be too afraid
and also the poll said trans women
rather than biological men
the actual question was should
transgender women be allowed to compete
in high school and college women's
sports
now plenty of people don't even know
what the phrase trans women means lots
of them think that a trans woman
is a woman a female who identifies as
trans now rephrase that poll to make it
more accurate and clearer
ask people if biological males don't say
anything about trans
should biological males
be allowed to compete against women
if you ask that question just like that
the no's are going to reach into the
90th percentile
all of this to say
the republican governor of utah stood
against the majority
took the less popular stance out of fear
of the noisy minority
this is the type of gutlessness
that plagues the republican party
and sadly conservatism generally
it's only
through this sort of compliance and and
submissiveness
that the left has been able to seize
hold of our culture and make their most
radical ideas mainstream in the first
place
so if we have any hope of reclaiming the
culture it has to start by identifying
the cowards and the turncoats on the
traders and exiling them
and we can start with spencer cox
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right so we'll start from the daily
wire it says
netflix and tick tock announced on
sunday that they have
suspended their services inside russia
following russian president vladimir
putin's decision to invade ukraine
netflix said a statement given the
circumstances on the ground we've
decided to suspend our service in russia
um the verge added last week netflix
said it wouldn't comply with a new
russia law that requires large streamers
to host 20 russian propaganda channels
such as ntv and the state-backed channel
one
the state-backed channel one is what's
called the streaming giant later
announced that it's halting all
productions and acquisitions in russia
netflix have been working on four
russian originals at the time
netflix currently has around one million
subscribers in russia so all of them are
out of luck now then tick tock announced
on sunday that it was also suspending
its services inside russia for safety
reasons
uh they said tick tock is an outlet for
creativity and entertainment that could
provide a source of relief and human
connection during a time of war when
people are
facing immense tragedy and isolation
according to the company's statement
however our highest priority is the
safety of our employees and our users
and in light of russia's new fake news
law we have no choice but to suspend
live streaming and new content to our
video service in russia while we review
the safety implications of this law now
the first thing that you think is uh
okay they got rid of
netflix they don't have tiktok this is
actually in many ways
the best thing that could happen to the
russian people in a lot of ways uh next
thing you know like mcdonald's and all
the fast food giants are gonna are gonna
boycott russia as well
and that's when it really backfires
because now russia becomes the strongest
and healthiest country in the entire
world because these are the the this is
the only country these companies won't
go go into but it also raises the
question of um
okay netflix is suspending its
service
in russia
first of all
how is that how does that punish putin
exactly
so i guess that means putin can't go on
and binge watch tiger king but something
tells me he's not worried about doing
that right now so if it punishes anybody
it punishes the people in russia and
nobody else
and if we're doing that if we are if we
are
punishing the people in a country
because of what their governments are
doing
and if these major corporations are
taking these
this this kind of stand
then
what about netflix service in china
uh what about tiktok in china the
chinese government essentially runs tick
tock so we certainly know that that they
still have tick tock in china
what about that
and if you really want to
extend this logic as far as it will go
when you're punishing the people for
what their governments are doing i don't
know if
i don't know if any of us are going to
be safe at the end of that certainly
we've got to take netflix out of canada
as well
just to start with but it doesn't end
there i'm going back to the daily wire
report it says numerous financial
service companies announced over the
weekend that they were suspending uh
operations in russia as well due to the
invasion american express announced on
sunday that they were suspending all
operations in russia and then
it was visa
pulled out mastercard
all of these companies are saying we're
not going to operate in russia anymore
as far as i know this is the first time
we've seen anything like this with all
of these major companies all at once
suspending operations in an entire
country
in uh at
in revenge out of vengeance for what
that government is doing
and the follow-up to the story by the
way of all the um
financial organizations pulling out of
russia is that as i was just reading a
different headline is that now russia is
turning to china to make up for all of
this
so you can't have visa you can't have
mastercard now they're going to go to
for all their banking needs and all
their financial needs now they're going
to rely on china even more than they did
before how does that help us how does
that help the west in the long run
to send russia and russians uh fleeing
even more into the arms of china
so when we start punishing the people of
russia i
uh i know how that can hurt i can
imagine all the ways that i will hurt
strengthening the bond between russia
and china which we don't want
turning russians against the west even
more
when they already it seems
there's there's a strong anti-war
contingent and feeling among russians
at least based on what we're being told
by western media that this this war is
unpopular in russia as it is
so you could flip that sentiment against
you
that's the bad that that's the bad thing
that can happen okay that's the negative
that's the loss
but what's the win
what's the advantage
what do we gain from this is my question
and i i can't help but uh keep going
back to this this point here that
uh after 9 11
we were constantly warned like the very
next day
uh the the one of the first priorities
one of the number one priorities after 9
11 was to make sure that there was no
islamophobia
in fact prior to 9 11 i'm not sure i
even ever heard the phrase islamophobia
after 9 11 is when it uh is when it
became mainstream
and we kept hearing about this problem
of islamophobia so we were very in our
in our country there was this intense
focus on making sure
that
regular muslim people
are not held responsible
for what some muslims did
and then you fast forward a little bit
and china
invents a virus in a lab unleashes it on
the world one way or another kills five
million people and again what's one of
the first things we hear
that we can't have uh anti-asian hate
has to stop
you know there's a plague of anti-asian
hate which is an even bigger epidemic
even bigger plague than covet itself
to so much as call
uh the coronavirus the china virus
is itself an act it's a hate crime
against asians
and yet with with russia
now all of a sudden it's yeah hold hold
hold them all accountable
punish all russian people
go and vandal there's russian
restaurants and stores here vandalize
them no big deal
why is that it would almost seem as
though the idea is that um because
russian people are perceived as white
even though a great many of them really
are not but they're perceived as white
and so therefore it's bigotry against
them and punishing them for what their
government is doing is okay whereas you
could never do that against the chinese
people because they're not white
now speaking of ukraine i wanted to play
this clip for you bryce mitchell is a
star in the ufc and
usually i'm not a big fan when athletes
are at press conferences and they're
supposed to be talking about their sport
but they're asked a question about
you know some political issue or
geopolitical issue even worse
but that happened here for whatever
reason they stopped this guy at his
press conference and they asked what do
you think of russia and ukraine
and this is
one of the most
cogent
analyses i think i've heard on the
entire issue coming from a guy in the
ufc who begins by saying i don't know a
lot about it but what follows from there
is far more sensible
and rational than most of what you hear
on cable news listen to this well i just
wanted to get your thoughts on the whole
russia and ukraine situation
you know um
here's my first starters i'm not going
nowhere to fight none of these wars for
these politicians i'm staying at home
and when the war comes to arkansas i
will dig my boots in the ground and i
will die for everything i love and i
will not retreat
if this country is invaded and
everybody's saying well we gotta we
gotta evacuate we gotta leave we got i
will not i will dig my boots into
arkansas soil and i will fight for the
people that i love for the land that i
love and the way life that i love but
i'm not going overseas to fight
i don't know what's going on to be
honest brother i really don't there's so
much stuff and i don't think nobody
knows what's going on fully there's been
so much political corruption in that
area you got biden and his son making a
ton of money
off of uh and using our tax dollars to
bribe
their people that's treasonous in my
opinion so you got hunter biden and his
son using our tax dollars hey if if
ukrainian government if you don't do
this we're taking your tax dollars he
shouldn't be giving our tax dollars to
that country anyway we got veterans out
here sleeping on the street and you're
gonna give our freaking tax dollars to
these ukrainians and all i'd rather i
don't know what's going on over there
but i'm not going over there and
fighting and god bless anybody that's
over there's fighting and i hope that
this just gets solved and man i don't
like war
you know what i mean i don't want people
dying and all that stuff i don't want to
be but i don't know what's going on
there's so much stuff that i think
that's corrupted that we just don't know
what's truly going on over there
an agent of putin obviously i mean when
you hear that right the only conclusion
you can draw as a rational person is
that he is uh
that he is being directly paid by putin
himself
and he is pro-putin and he wants ukraine
to be invaded and all ukrainians to be
killed in the massive genocide that's
that's what we have to i mean at least
that's what we're told like if you're
if you
waver from the established narrative on
this at all then you're pro-putin
that's what we're told anyway or
you know you can have some common sense
and realize that this is you know
the reason why this is a cogent analysis
is that it starts number one by
admitting
how little you know about what's going
on
and i wish that more people had this
kind of humility from the very beginning
okay because as i said before you know
before the invasion actually happened we
started hearing about uh the potential
that it would happen
but what
one of the first things i said on the
show is that is that
in the coming days you're going to hear
a lot of people talking about ukraine
and they're going to have
very firm opinions on ukraine
and 99 of those people have never even
thought about ukraine prior to that
moment when it was in the news cycle
what's more how many of them this is
what i want to know how many of all the
people that have got ukraine
flags in their profiles right now how
many of them could point to it on a map
without cheating without using google if
i showed them a map
of of that part of europe
without any labels how many of them
could point to ukraine
less than 50
less than 25 percent
and that's
i mean there is a woeful lack in
geographic knowledge among americans so
it is a general problem but the fact
that most people haven't really thought
about ukraine don't know a lot about the
the the historic tensions between
ukraine and russia which by the way
didn't just start this past week
there's a history there
and as much as we want to be told that
it's a very clear good guy versus bad
guy
uh dynamic it's actually not quite that
clear when you go through the history of
it
which is almost always the case when it
comes to feuds and tensions between
people and between nations
so i've said this before about i said
this before about about marriages that
fall apart and sometimes it's it's
really clear in a marriage there's a bad
guy and there's a good guy you know
sometimes that's the case sometimes
someone's just a total monster and the
other person is uh practically insane
and that happens sometimes but most of
the time you'll get that impression when
you hear just one person's side of the
story but if you go and hear the other
person's side you're going to hear d now
you might still after hearing the other
person's side be on the original
person's side but you're going to hear
details that make you go oh i didn't
know about that that's interesting
so that's the case about when it comes
to tensions between people especially
when it comes to tensions between
governments
there are no saintly governments in the
world
doesn't mean that there are no bad guys
and good guys when it comes to
individual conflicts
russia is the bad guy here they're the
one invading
but the point is there's a history okay
that most people just don't know and
it's okay to not know because we can't
know everything uh a lot of a lot of us
can't really can't really know anything
at all it seems like but we certainly
can't know everything
and you're going to be focused primarily
and justifiably
on the things happening right around you
in your own country
but all that means is that when
something starts to happen 6 000 miles
away
and the media and and you start
and there's there's just sort of one
version of events that you're hearing
from the media
and the media assigns you a position
that you're supposed to have
and says anyone who does not have this
position this exact position is whatever
bad terrible label they come up with the
moment that happens there should be some
skepticism
and you should stop and say well you
know
i don't really know a lot about this i'm
very far removed from it
and all the information i'm getting
right now is from the media and i don't
really trust them
and so that's when you take um
the position that bryce mitchell took
there i think which is a very sensible
position all right one other note here
on uh ukraine
george takai tweeted this i just wanted
to show this to you um he says americans
we can endure higher prices for food and
gas if it means putting the screws to
putin consider it a patriotic donation
in the fight for freedom over tyranny
george takai is uh
obviously a hero willing to make a
sacrifice
yeah we should be able to sacrifice we
should sacrifice uh for the sake of the
people of ukraine
now i'm i'm going to take a different
position uh i'm going to say no
i i don't really see why
we as americans
should have to make any sacrifices
necessarily
because of this conflict that's going on
overseas
and it's really easy to say
you know i'm i'm not looking at an
american family right sitting around the
dinner table and it's i'm not sure i can
make the pitch to them that you should
have to make sacrifices in your life
significant sacrifices because of
ukraine and russia
now george takai can can take that
position and it's an easy one for him to
take and he could pretend to be that
he's making a sacrifice and then he's
being so heroic and selfless
but george sakai is old as dirt
childless and rich
rich by the way from doing nothing like
he was in star trek
85 years ago and since then has done
nothing at all and but it's just made
all the royalties and everything and
merchandise and whatever else so he's
just sitting back doing nothing at all
for the for the last uh 60 years of his
life he's rich he doesn't have any kids
he's not going to be around much longer
he's in his 80s
and so it's easy for him to say oh yeah
we can endure these higher prices
when you're worth 20 million dollars and
have no dependents sure it's higher
prices for food you barely even notice
it
but for a lot a lot of american families
are not in that position
all right
white house chief of staff ron clayne on
thursday signaled that the white house
would extend the freeze on student loan
payments again
following no mention of student loans in
the state of union earlier in the week
clayne was on the podcast pod save
america and he spoke about this in fact
we have the video and let's play that
now
the president's going to
uh look at what we should do on student
debt
before
[Music]
the pause expires or he'll extend the
pause joe biden right now is the only
president in history where no one's paid
on their student loans for the entirety
of his presidency and so the question
whether or not there's some executive
action student debt forgiveness uh when
the payments resume uh is a decision
we're going to take before the payments
resume
uh right now um people aren't aren't
having to pay on their loans and um and
so i think dealing with the executive
branch question what we should do about
that what his powers are how much we
should do on that that's something we're
going to deal with later on
yeah the the question that is uh not
answered yeah we're going to look at
maybe we'll pause the student loans um
a few questions number one is where and
i know that this is such a moot point
now because you know
uh
the the the executive branch has long
since become this kind of monarchical
maybe has always been in a certain way
uh institution and it has claimed for
itself the power to do basically
anything that it wants
um so we we've lived in that world for
forever basically and then ever since
covet it's only gotten worse you know
when you have the um
when you have
organizations or you know agencies in in
the federal government that can say to
landlords just the decree that you're
not allowed to evict
people who don't pay their rent you know
delinquent tenants are not allowed to
evict them well we'll we'll let you know
when you're allowed to uh to do that
again
and there was there's never any
explanation of where they derived that
authority and same thing here where
exactly
where exactly
does the president
find the authority to just put a pause
on student loans
and and also why why are we doing this
exactly
because they're talking about for
there's there's this
obviously this conflict here this
contradiction because on one hand
they're bragging about the bite
administration's bragging about the
unemployment rate that's going down and
people are getting back to work and the
economy is doing great
which what they don't mention by the way
when they when they're bragging about
how the unemployment rate is going down
is that they had for a long time stopped
people from working
they they've locked people in a cage
basically and said you're not allowed to
work and then they unlocked the cage and
opened it and said look at all these
people working we've created jobs
no you've just you've just
pulled back from stopping them from
doing something that they were doing
before you stop them from doing it
but if the economy is roared back to
life and we're doing we're in great
shape and hey but don't look at the uh
inflation don't check the gas prices
don't look at the food prices but
everything don't don't look at that
behind the curtain over there
everything's doing great if that's if
that's the case then why even more so
why are we extending the pause on
student loans
and also why student loans is the
question i always ask about this
is of all the bills and debts that
people have
um i have plenty like anybody else i
have plenty of bills of my own that i
have to pay um debts that i have to pay
including my mortgage why are student
loans special exactly
why do we why do they get the kind of
pride of place
those questions never answered obviously
this is from politico says eric adams
has a problem with chocolate milk new
york's first self-perfect self-professed
vegan mayor was at the forefront of a
movement to ban chocolate milk from
public schools before his time in city
hall now equipped with the power to set
policies for the nation's largest school
system the evangelist for healthy living
has again turned his attention to the
lunchroom staple and registered concern
with the state's powerful dairy industry
he said we're having a conversation
about should we have chocolate high
sugar milk in our schools
now i'm not going to become nanny mayor
but we do need to have our children but
we do need to
we do need to have our children have
options i think it means we need to have
children to have options
he doesn't want to be the nanny mayor it
goes on for a long time talking about
this debate over chocolate milk and i've
already lost interest so i can't read
any more of it but he doesn't want to be
the nanny mayor
and yet he's uh very concerned about
chocolate milk in schools
and if this annoys you well you have to
remember as always
is that um
is that
this is how the government looks at
public schools
you know when you send your kid to
public school you are sending your kid
into the care of
the government these are government
schools
as i've said that we should rather than
calling them public schools
uh i think a better word would just be
government schools
because it emphasizes what you're
actually doing you're sending your kid
into a government building to be taken
to be cared for by government employees
and that means that the people at the
top people running
the government are going to feel like
you know they're
they they basically are the nannies
and um so you're gonna have these kind
of nanny state laws
and in some ways they're they're
actually right because
the government school system is one
giant kind of free day care not really
free because it actually costs a lot of
money but you don't have to pay upfront
for it um
it's one giant daycare or sort of nanny
system
and that's where you get rules like this
and i actually i will say
i mean i think it's it's incredibly
stupid for uh the the mayor of new york
to be focused on chocolate milk in
schools at all
i mean
if you're the mayor of new york
and you've got homeless people running
rampant
throwing you know down in the subway
throwing people in front of trains and
all those kind of stuff and crime and
violence is uh is reaching record highs
and spiking like it is in every other
major city then that should be 100 of
your focus basically and you can get to
chocolate milk once you've solved all
those problems which you never will so
that means you're never going to get to
it
but all that being said
i do actually think um that you can have
chocolate milk in schools it's fine but
it's it's not a crazy thing to think
about the diet that these kids are being
fed in schools what kind of food they're
being fed
only because
when they're in the the government
school system
they're sitting at desks
for like seven hours a day doing busy
work
which is already almost impossible for a
lot of kids to do especially boys and
that's why many of them get diagnosed
with adhd and drugged
but considering that very challenging
environment you've put them in very
unnatural environment
anything you feed them with artificial
sugars or anything like that you only
make it all the all the more difficult
for them to sit still and
and pay attention so something else to
think about as well let's get now to the
comment section
this is from matthew du plessis says for
a minute i thought matt was going to
enter the women's swimming championships
got way too excited now that i think
about it uh well i could you know beard
and all i could probably just jump in
the pool and enter the competition um
now i mean you could say that i'm not
actually a student of any school um
any ncaa school or any other school but
then again why does that matter maybe i
identify as being a student um i even
though i'm a man i wouldn't like my
chances actually competing against women
in swimming because because i well
because i can't swim i'm a pretty good
doggy paddler that's my move
and uh my wife anytime we're in any kind
of lake or pool or ocean she can't stop
laughing at me looking at me kind of
like doggy paddling around but that's
i'm not ever going to be in a position
where i need to actually swim the doggy
paddle's good enough for me but i will
be at uh georgia tech
around the time when this uh when the
ncaa women's swimming championships are
happening and leah thomas the male will
be competing against the females and
i'll be there at georgia tech to explain
why that's wrong that'll be monday
uh march 14th at 5 30 and stay tuned for
more details on that as well okay doc
holliday says
any man that is called matt sweet daddy
big daddy or any form of the word daddy
forfeits their man card forever
uh
under most circumstances i would agree
with you doc holliday but i'm gonna
allow an exception in this case
troopy says how has matt managed to
avoid the daily wires show subscribe to
continue viewing video cut whatever the
reason thanks for always having been
there for the dw freeloading crew
i actually wish i hadn't read this
comment because i don't want to call
attention to the fact that we don't do
that here i don't know either is your
question but i
let's just move on
um
let's see
erica says the term authentic self has
to be the most annoying phrase ever
uttered
yeah i i agree that it's annoying
because of how it's so often used and i
think you're referring to we talked
about the
the sports illustrated
cover fluff piece the cover piece about
leah thomas and he was talking about how
now that he's grown his hair out as
pretending to be a woman that he's
living his authentic self
and i agree that that's completely
absurd obviously because that's the
exact opposite of what he's doing he is
rejecting his authentic self
and
any
pain or discomfort that he's
experiencing right now internally is is
grounded in that and that he has
rejected his authentic self
um
but that's exactly why the phrase itself
i don't have a problem with
because we do have
a a huge issue in our culture a crisis
level problem i think
of people rejecting their authentic self
you know because there's your authentic
self and then there's the
your your self perception
and those are not necessarily the same
and in fact
for probably everybody they don't
exactly line up right
we all
you know for all of us you are a certain
type of person you are a certain way you
look a certain way you act certainly
have a certain personality
but your perception of who you are is
probably not 100 accurate
for better or worse
you might think you're uglier than you
actually are uh you might think you're
dumber than you actually are i think for
a lot of people their sub perception
goes the other way unfortunately though
so
authentic self and self perception i
think those are two phrases that we
actually need don't take
your frustrations out on the phrases
um and this should be our message to
people
that you know true harmony
and um
you know happiness in life comes in part
from this alignment between your self
perception and your authentic self and
you should try to line those things up
well this is another big week at the
daily wire why because this thursday
night march 10th we're premiering yet
another film and uh we cannot wait to
share it with you that film is called
the hyperions and it's exactly what
entertainment in hollywood is often
missing these days it's not woke it has
zero underlying political message and
it's just uh well it's an excellent film
because when it comes to entertainment
that's all that matters if you don't
believe me check out the trailer good
day hyperion club members
[Music]
[Applause]
we've come for one thing
our titan badges this titan badge can
grant an individual superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
on my way
[Music]
[Applause]
she's trying to destroy me
so the hyperions is a dysfunctional
family film with throwback vibes and
it's 100 worth the stream we'll be
streaming the film
once on march 10th for all of youtube to
see this is the last time we're going to
be giving the movie away to you
freeloaders after this you have to be a
daily wire member
which means go to dailywire.com
subscribe so that you don't miss any
more of uh all the content that we have
coming your way also you know it's
always time for new voices to enter the
transgender conversation because as
always diversity is extremely important
and you know if you know anything about
me the first thing you know about me is
that i value diversity and equity and
inclusion and tolerance most of all
that's why i author the best-selling
children's lgbtq plus book um literary
sensation
the most influential lgbt uh piece of
literature ever written johnny the
walrus and um as you know i was invited
on dr phil to talk about it as well you
can see those clips even more
importantly if you haven't picked up a
copy of my best-selling children's book
which is sitting
so subtly behind me
at this hotel because i bring it with me
on trips this is my reading material i
just read it over and over again on
flights i i read it in my hotel room
and through each successive reading it's
so layered that you pick up on
additional things you didn't see the
first time
so go to
jointhewalrus.com or go to amazon and
get your copy now finally the media
loves to amp amplify one side of any
story it's always the one that agrees
with the narrative they're pushing
that's why we've taken it upon ourselves
to start our own publishing wing called
dw books
and uh of which i think gina walbrush
was the very first thing that we
published with our new publishing
imprint which is a point of pride at
least for me i don't know about for
anybody else
but we've got a lot more coming down the
pike including
12 seconds in the dark by sergeant
mattingly the book is the true story of
what really happened the night of the
tragic briana taylor shooting mattingly
a 20-year police veteran takes readers
inside his department's response and
debunks the lies that have recklessly
been shared with the public check out
the trailer
it was very chaotic it was very quick
instantly i know of a shot brianna
taylor she was caught in the crossfire
of those bullets as soon as your brain's
registering it's already over the media
got so many things wrong in this case
saying we had the wrong apartment her
name wasn't on the warrant she was shot
and killed in her sleep in her bed these
are lies this is not true and all the
while you're hearing all these outside
influences from athletes and oprah and
ellen degeneres and kamala harris and
joe biden all those people coming and
attacking you putting your name on their
account saying he should be in prison
all these things that they have no idea
what they're talking about but they have
such influence the more we attack police
for doing their job the less good
qualified police you're going to have
[Music]
when you read 12 seconds in the dark you
will find out the truth of what really
happened the night of the brianna taylor
raid
[Music]
you know in a world where voices like
his are censored this story is
incredibly important and we're so
grateful to have this brave truth teller
on board the book releases march 15th
but it's available for pre-order right
now on amazon or anywhere you buy books
online so after you buy 10 more copies
of johnny the walrus then go get that
book as well get your pre-ordered copy
today because i promise you it will sell
out now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
you know there are some conservatives
who say that we should not punch right
and i mostly agree but with the
stipulation that the most common form of
punching right
is when people on the right punch
themselves directly in their own faces
and when i see people on the right
giving themselves right hooks to the
skull
i feel the need to chime in and say
knock it off and this is sometimes
interpreted as me punching right but
really it's the opposite this is like
i'm trying to to help them i'm not the
one doing the punching the punches are
self-inflicted and that brings us
finally to the so-called people's convoy
which um
which
made it or maybe it's the freedom combo
which
one is the canadian one one is this one
anyway it made its way to dc um or
rather around dc this weekend now this
convoy is a sort of sequel to the
canadian convoy and
it's it like most hollywood reboots it
lacks much of the appeal and i think
almost all of the point of the original
the only real similarity between the two
is that they both feature protesting
truckers but beyond that the connection
kind of breaks down here's the
washington post with their report of um
what happened yesterday when they all
arrived
an armada of drivers calling themselves
the people's convoy okay so it is the
people's conflict is circling the
beltway at a deliberately slow speed
sunday as an act of protest against
pandemic restrictions organizers said
their goal was to be a huge pain quote
unquote although the convoy of hundreds
of trucks cars and suvs started out
moving in a formation that that
stretched roughly 30 miles it became
diluted after merging with normal
beltway traffic as of 2 30 pm sunday the
convoy was well into its second loop
around the district the vehicles were
spread out in groups on interstate 495's
outer loop going about 40 miles an hour
traffic was flowing around them as usual
at about 55 miles an hour quote we're
not even sure that we can call it a
convoy anymore because it's so dispersed
among routine traffic at this point said
virginia state police spokeswoman
corrine geller the group intends to
repeat its beltway loop every day this
week according to organizer brian brays
the group says that it will increase the
number of trips around the beltway each
day to pressure lawmakers and public
officials while the disruption of
motorists caused on the disruption
the motorists cause on sunday was
minimal their presence could create far
more chaos during a weekday when beltway
traffic is already thick with commuters
okay so
as of sunday
the convoy had simply been absorbed by
the traffic and had really accomplished
nothing
and that may be all it ever achieves
unless with the help of a of a workday
rush hour um it manages in the days
ahead to to create the huge pain that it
wants to create and make make beltway
traffic even worse than it usually is
those are the two best case scenarios
right
that it does nothing
um that's one best case scenario or it
creates a huge inconvenience
the worst case scenarios are that things
somehow get out of hand out of control
uh some kind of violence happens as a
result
maybe there's a road rage incident maybe
a trucker is involved in an accident
that kills somebody uh you know i'm not
saying that will happen those but those
are the worst cases
so again best case
nothing happens or only something
moderately bad happens which is a lot of
traffic and it annoys people worst case
something worse than moderately bad
happens
so you might be asking
what's the win here
what which of these results do the
truckers
involved hope to see happen
or have they imagined some other fantasy
scenario do they think that after a week
of circling the beltway uh biden will
hold a press conference agreeing to give
the truckers anything that they demand
well the problem with that hope is that
it 100 will not happen but second it's
not even clear what they're demanding
exactly so even if you wanted to give
them what they demand you really can't
so let's break this down
here's why the people's convoy is is uh
less than less than a smart idea
and wyatt has got another example of
people on the right beating the hell out
of themselves much like that scene in
fight club with ed norton first
we're two years into this most of the
very worst mandates and policies have
already been lifted
even the deepest blue cities are finally
loosening their restrictions
and the truckers have chosen now
two years later when all this stuff is
going away it's at this very moment
when we're when when we're going to have
this demonstration
at the moment when we're already
starting to win the covent fight finally
now we stage the demonstration
why now of all times the baby
administration is losing the battle on
the coveted narrative
you might say they've already basically
lost it and they're losing in every
other way also everywhere democrats are
barreling towards a historic landslide
annihilation in the midterms all this
can do if it does anything is distract
from the hapless incompetence of the
flailing democrats and give them a shiny
object to point to a villain to demonize
and say look at these right-wing
extremists making your life harder
showing no respect for you as a working
man making it harder for you to get to
work making it harder for you to get
home to get home to your families and
your children after work
that's what they'll say if they feel the
need to acknowledge this at all
what they certainly will not say is you
know what because these random truckers
circled the beltway 98 times we're now
gonna renounce our evil leftist ways and
and willingly forfeit our positions of
power
i feel certain that they will not say
that
second point one of the reasons i know
they won't say that
is that this protest is very
specifically being done in a way
so as to cause no pain at all to the
actual leftist lawmakers in dc who are
ostensibly its targets
so the truckers are are
at least based on what was going on on
sunday trying to cause gridlock on the
already gridlocked dc beltway
um or at least you know
more traffic than usual i mean they're
not stopping their trucks in the middle
of the highway but you know slowing down
intentionally and trying to cause
traffic
what they perhaps don't understand is
that dc politicians are mostly living
inside the beltway in dc itself their
offices are a few blocks away from where
they live
most of them fly into dc on the rare odd
occasion where they actually have to do
some work
and they either stay in a hotel or like
an aoc's case they have expensive homes
that they rent in the fancy parts of
town they don't get on the beltway to
get to work
okay so they're going to be totally
unaffected by this aoc and nancy pelosi
aren't going to be sitting in traffic
behind the wheel pulling their hair out
frustrated and reassessing their life
choices that's not going to happen do
you know who will have that experience
if the truckers succeed in being a quote
huge pain regular working people
the dc beltway is not a secret vip
passageway used by the elite when
they're going to meet at their creepy
eyes wide shut sex dungeons it's
actually just a highway where people who
live in maryland in virginia drive to
work and many of them are normal
blue-collar people
now there might be some lawyers and
lobbyists and assorted nerd whales in
the mix but there are a lot of just
hourly wage workers blue collar types
soccer moms and so on speaking of soccer
moms
they just helped us deliver a huge win
in virginia
and for their troubles now they're gonna
be punished by this uh convoy as well
here's the thing if you want someone to
hate you
i mean just viscerally hate you
despise you with every fiber of their
being
the kind of hatred where they they sit
and fantasize about terrible and violent
things happening with you
if you want to make that happen then go
to a busy highway during rush hour and
intentionally cause more congestion
i can think of no more efficient way
to be hated by more people all at once
of all political persuasions is this the
goal
to be hated by normal people who commit
the sin of needing to use the highway
between 6 and 9 a.m on a weekday
to make matters worse the people who are
causing this inconvenience
or who or tried calling it cause it
anyway can't even really explain why
they're doing it
now supporters say that it's about
pandemic restrictions but when you point
out that most of those restrictions are
already gone and the rest are probably
on their way out
and the ones that maybe will be around
for a long time exist in certain
contexts where you think that the
protests will be more targeted like like
airports for example now those
restrictions may never go away and those
are federal restrictions but so why
aren't you protesting at an airport if
you're gonna protest at all
not that i'm advocating anybody causing
more congestion at airports because
that's not gonna help anything either
but um when you point that out
um
what you're told what you're given in
response are kind of vague platitudes
about freedom and unity and as one
person told me on twitter this is about
people standing together
and someone else told me well they don't
need to explain themselves to you
your busybody they have a right to
demonstrate well yeah they do have a
right but if you're not willing or able
to explain your demonstration it is
inherently a pointless and
counterproductive demonstration
demonstrations are supposed to well
demonstrate something send a message
push for some specific end so what does
this demonstrate
other than the participants lack of
originality for one and their total
disregard for the other people on the
roadway
um but by far
the worst defense that i've heard of
this
is when is is that well hey at least
they're doing something
but doing something is certainly not
always better than doing nothing okay
doing nothing is zero that's a zero
doing something counterproductive is a
negative
and zero is better than a negative
that's just mathematics
you know what the at least they're doing
something mentality got us it got us
january 6th
which was which was not an insurrection
or a terrorist attack but it was an
incredibly stupid and monumentally
counterproductive event in which a lot
of people went out and did something
without stopping for even a moment to
think about whether the thing they're
doing has any chance at all of actually
helping spoiler it didn't it had no
chance of helping and it's not helping
unless the plan was to help the
democrats in the left which it certainly
did succeed in doing
you know if i'm upset about the income
tax
i could put on a clown suit
and jump on a pogo stick while singing
the macarena you know
and i would be doing something i mean
you couldn't if you came up to me and
said why are you doing this at least i'm
doing something
it's something certainly it is something
but the something i'm doing only makes
me look like in this case a literal
clown it bring it brings attention to me
it lets me blow off steam in my own
personal way
but if i was hoping to achieve a
reduction in the income tax it's hard to
see how my pogo stick clown suit plan
will achieve that goal
yet this is what we so often do on the
right we we you know
people go out and just do things
we do a whole lot of things
doing a whole lot of somethings
yet it doesn't really accomplish
anything because there's not much
strategy behind it
now that's not always the case of course
there are plenty of people on the right
who know how to think strategically who
know how to win and how to stage a
demonstration cause a scene while
advancing their agenda at the same time
if i may say so humbly i have myself
been involved in more than one of these
kinds of successful demonstrations
what's the difference between the
successful ones and the pointless circus
acts well
if you're on the successful site you
know what your win looks like you have
clear goals in mind you know what a win
is
you know what the potential loss would
be and you've roughly calculated the
chances of the loss against the chances
of the win you've determined that the
win is sufficiently more likely and that
it's worth the risk of the loss you've
also thought about how this will play
what it will look like what the optics
will be if you don't care about optics
you know then then you shouldn't be in
the protest game because protests are
all about optics that's the whole point
you've also considered how your enemies
might sabotage what you're doing and you
know what your counterpunch will be
in each case
perhaps most importantly of all you can
explain exactly what you're doing and
why you're doing it you have a message
everyone involved knows the message and
they stay on message
and you drill that message every chance
you get
you're more than happy to explain
yourself in fact that's the whole reason
that you're doing what you're doing you
have a point
and you want nothing more than to
explain that point
this is how we we and when i say we i
mean not just me obviously but lots of
people on the right helped to flip
virginia red no small feat
but this were these were targeted acts
of demonstration with specific goals in
mind we knew what the wind is and we
stayed on message
the message in virginia was parental
rights that was the message
stay on it and you you
beat on that drum every chance you get
it can't be well it's this and it's also
this and also just freedom and also this
generally and also unity and harmony and
all the good things and rainbows and
puppy dogs that can't be it
um
that's how we flip virginia red anyway
but you know with a lot of traffic on
the dc beltway maybe our trucker friends
will help to flip it blue again who
knows there's a better chance of that
than of whatever positive result they
have in their minds and that ultimately
is why they are i'm afraid to say uh
today canceled and we'll leave it there
for today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavo valdoski our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily dailywire
2022.
america destroys russia's economy
lindsey graham calls for assassinating
putin and the media claims straight guys
enjoy kissing and snuggling with their
buddies check it out on the michael
knoll show